[Music]
[Music]
this whole
wartime prophecy the whole yeah this is
basically in the past week we've
realized that everything we talked about
all the cool you know i mean they're not
cool they're still like [ __ ] war
stories but like
the guy that you know like shot down six
russian planes the ghost of kyov and eve
keith i knew that was fake
snake island all those people yeah
apparently i told the russians to [ __ ]
off or whatever fake they surrendered
potentially still alive which is cool
yeah the old lady talking to russian
soldiers fake that didn't happen right
the fire at the nuclear plane i don't
think that happened there's also like
this i don't know is this rumor going
around that like
i don't last very long and bad that is
totally fake no no that one i think was
verified no no no no no no no no no no
yeah no no russia came out with that oh
i saw that on cnn nah yeah i see cnn
takes debate sometimes too yeah that's
just the kgb coming after me
so yeah there was one about how like
bagels yeah yeah that one is true yeah
oh damn it yeah
so funny to think about finishing early
and then
just pausing to have like a
paranoid freak out to cover up that you
nutted early
oh oh oh we have to take a break
wait a second
you pull out
what's wrong wait a second
hold on hold on hold on
pull out your computers like i just
i didn't write this email i forgot it i
have to respond to this email i'm so
[ __ ] for god i forgot i was like i was
in i was in the midst of an ebay auction
it's the last day i just gotta check if
there's any other bids
it's just gonna it's just gonna take me
a second
you're looking up porn
[Laughter]
trying to get rehard yeah rehard
regard
[Laughter]
trying to rehard myself yeah
you know yeah i'm on the option right
now it's a
it's an antique
like
feeling your own dick again try
pulling on it trying to get it up it's
an antique
pinball machine it's just
just yanking it
it's pulling it up
it's elastic just right back towards
come on come on yeah it's i still have
the top bit it seems it's just gonna
close in three minutes i just gotta bang
this out and then you know we'll get
right back to it
this is really quietly on the computer
speakers
what what is going on there not even
turning down the volume
yeah vintage pinball was crazy
just a demo
yeah dude wartime propaganda yeah it's
all um
yeah apparently russia's not even real
yeah exactly
it's just incredible how effective it is
yeah
everybody fell for it
yeah i mean
this is pretty uh
it's pretty disheartening you know you
want to stay educated or you want to
like be in tune with things yeah and
then it's just no way to be
only way to be just hammers it hammers a
really
um
it encourages apathy yeah fortunately
yeah i know
i'm just uh
you know this is the alex jones podcast
now
it does seem though
as of today a couple hours ago
that russia was proposing some sort of
peace treaty i guess if they get the
donbass and they get
crimea crimea crimea cremia cremia i
think so and uh and ukraine agrees like
never to join nato
and stay neutral or something like that
that they'd retreat or something
which kind of seems like the best
of all worlds right now it's probably
the best option that we have
yeah maybe
we don't know what we don't know i guess
i mean i don't know
never joining nato
i saw sam moral doing a bit about nato
it's like
he's like the first three countries
sound
really stellar
it's like usa
uk
you get you get to like player number
four
and it's like uh
iceland
yeah do they have a nuke yeah
yeah they have an army yeah
so
you know
i don't know i don't know if nato is
because then
like i think ukraine like fast track to
like join the eu
is that real is that gonna happen
i don't know
russia is interesting
in terms of like
uh
at least like with the fall of the
soviet union that dude bald and bankrupt
you remember him yeah so like he's
trying his videos i didn't watch his
ones about ukraine oh it was crazy i
mean isn't it nuts that i think when i
first brought him up
on the podcast i swear he had like a
hundred thousand subscribers yeah
and that was i think four or five years
ago and that dude that dude's like two
three million subscribers now yeah
killing it i watched
i watched his video uh the ukrainian one
he was like
basically the day that the war broke out
or like as they were invading he was on
he took a bus to the ukrainian border
wow
it was just like walking around talking
to like villagers and stuff like that
yeah it's crazy how just you know he
goes straight to farmers not villagers
whatever yeah but like people that just
old people that live on the border
that they were like oh i just i don't
even know what's going on yeah
yeah i
what i like or some of my favorite stuff
from him is when he'll go
like um
he'll go to like republics
uh like old soviet republics and it's
like an interesting thing where
basically like within
the soviet union like republics were
created
that were correlated to like another
group of people so there'd be like a
belarus like republic that you could you
know go to
i guess after i'm not really sure what
the [ __ ] the soviet union took over
like exactly i just know they took a lot
of people and then displaced them
um but like some of those republics like
just still exist
and one recent video he
he's like yeah there's this one that
like
it's on this old ass map it's there's no
current reference to it on the internet
like you can't find it anywhere so i'm
just gonna drive there and see if it
still exists you'll just go there and it
will yeah and he'll like get in and just
be talking to people asking them
questions and [ __ ] like
it's like how long have you been here
since the collapse and
they're just a totally different world
yeah
so when it comes to like ukraine and
that whole [ __ ] i just feel like
it's so tough
at
being here and then like trying to even
understand because i feel like there's
so much historical context that we just
do not fully comprehend yeah just by way
of just being just like disconnected
from it yeah like
they don't have family that has like
lived through that [ __ ]
and has like a commentary on like no i
think the best resource is people's
instagram stories definitely
you know yeah i think that's the best
place where you can get information
yeah
unbiased
mostly true
the ones
the ones where like
they post the article but then they
shrink it down and then put a paragraph
of their own opinion over it yep and the
whole paragraph is chastising you about
why you're dumb yep and why you are a
problem
um but then you can never actually click
the article yeah because it's just why
would you need to yeah
their opinion is better that's true yeah
yeah that i mean like
from this whole situation i started like
writing this bit where
americans like
i see why people hate us
we're completely like the hot person at
the party
like we wake up every year or two and
we're like
dude wait you guys are like at war
this is so [ __ ] up yeah and then like
other countries are like bleeding from
their eye sockets and they're like yeah
no [ __ ] it's bad i'm like damn
and then americans like just hot people
turn to each other and they're like like
someone should do something about this
and they all just keep saying that to
each other yeah and then someone's like
dude
here's a check from my dad
and then the country's still like
bleeding and like [ __ ] hurting
they're like thanks bro that's funny and
then we travel there and we're like yo
airbnbs are down crazy now because of
the whole thing so i thought [ __ ] it why
don't i just like pull up and make some
videos pull up and like support the
local economy here and the airbnb hosts
and
just
mad cheap yeah
mad cheap i got a table tonight at some
club it was only five grand
just dude give it six months and wait
for [ __ ]
why i moved to ukraine yeah well be some
influencer
so i know it's really controversial but
i moved here and i'm doing my crypto
business from this ukrainian expat hotel
because of the taxes but no because i
wanted to support them you know
yeah in the economy
yeah plus their tax laws are sick yeah
so just it's just so funny how like
how
americans just make other [ __ ] about
themselves yeah do you see that you see
that [ __ ] i was watching trillionaire
and they were reacting to the clip of
whoever on the view that was like
had to like give her two cents and she's
like yeah i just i don't even know how
this is gonna affect like i'm pretty
concerned about how this is gonna affect
western europe like like i was planning
on going i'm going to italy this summer
and i just i don't know if that's still
going to be an option and i've never
been and it just like pisses me off that
i can't go
the most amazing however you can
however you can digest yeah war you know
maybe that's the way that she does it
you know
yeah no we should definitely be
supportive of that we should all be
actually running to her dm
okay why is that bad because people are
like dying oh
and you can't like poor people or
[Laughter]
i mean most of them poorer than you okay
so what why should i
well because maybe you can't go to italy
next summer oh what yeah
yeah
[ __ ] man war is bad yeah hold on i'ma
post some [ __ ] about this yeah
heartbreaking heartbroken at what i'm
seeing in ukraine yeah
literally
it's just it's so
it's so dumb bro
you